[Music]
villains are common in Disney movies but
some of them are worse than others stay
tuned to see which villain is king or
queen of them all if you like crafts and
DIYs check out our friends at crafty
hackers they have this awesome video
about ways you can recycle regular
objects into toys they'll show you how
to turn your useless everyday items into
amazing kiss toys make sure you check
them out
and be sure to leave them a like click
in the corner to watch new around here
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great content like this now on
to who is the most powerful Disney
villain Hans
Oh Anna if only there was someone out
there who loved you these dreadful words
were spoken by a true jerk I'm sure you
remember Hans from frozen he is
responsible for a huge plot twist that
you probably didn't see coming
him being the villain was a shock
because we all saw him as a good guy he
had us fooled thinking he loved Anna and
liked finishing her sentences sadly
turns out mr. Hans actually wanted Anna
and her sister Elsa out of the way so he
could be the ruler of arendelle everyone
believed he was this noble upstanding
guy that was on his crew of a courageous
prince you know it hit you hard to see
him turn into a monster and we know
violence is wrong but on apunching him
square in the face deserves praise x
doesn't really have any magical powers
but he preyed on the vulnerability of
two sisters which is awful within itself
despite the turmoil he caused he's still
a weakling you dog yeah you know
Cruella De Vil her name alone means
cruel devil so don't expect Cruella De
Vil to be a good Samaritan angel even if
her coats are nice the fashionista is
obsessed with herself and enjoys the
luxuries of everything every single
thing is expensive as possible and
authentic so what do you think her
iconic furs are made up precious puppies
fur everybody has a soft spot for the
little guy especially when the little
guys and girls are adorable puppies
Pirela is one of Disney's most disliked
villains her actions are despicable in
the movie she gets caught before her
plan comes to fruition if not this film
would not be suitable for anyone wicked
stepmother Cinderella's wicked
stepmother didn't need any magical
powers to torture her stepdaughter all
of her talents lie in her ability to
psychologically and emotionally abuse
the girl
Cinderella does nothing wrong to her
stepmother other than being an orphan
and a burden to her we see her being
treated like the help a slave that is
ordered to do chores until she can't
take it anymore Cinderella's stepsisters
and stepmother are practically drowning
in expensive fabrics and jewelry the
girl has no family no money or social
status so she has to rely on that evil
woman to earn her keep just the fact
that Lady Tremaine is able to abuse and
torture Cinderella for so many years
without anyone paying attention or even
caring shows that she has power she
forces her stepdaughter to live life
without having any fun showing her that
her self-confidence should be
non-existent in the real story Lady
Tremaine also makes her daughter's cut
off their own toes so they can fit into
the infamous slipper she has no magical
powers but tons of influence Gaston
Gaston's character develops in Beauty
and the Beast we see that he is prideful
with a huge ego and does not deal well
with rejection
he is baffled at Belle's decision to
turn down his marriage proposal and in
return becomes violent when we first
meet Gaston we just see that he's a
narcissist who is only concerned with
himself that doesn't make him a villain
just annoying we also need to point out
that Belle has a lot of great qualities
but guests
only sees her for being beautiful he is
determined to make her a trophy wife and
tries to force the girl into an unhappy
marriage he locks her father away in a
mental asylum after Belle goes missing
along with locking her father away
gaston tries to get rid of Belle's true
love Prince Adam in the end the Beast
defeats Gaston Gaston is pretty big and
has alliances who will do the dirty work
for him governor Ratcliffe he's racist
towards the natives and is rather
xenophobic he refers to the natives as
savages which shows how entitled he and
others are just from the color of their
skin and how they live lavishly it's
true that Radcliffe knew things at
Pocahontas and her tribe had no idea
about but he definitely would have not
lasted one day in Jamestown had it not
been westernized Ratcliffe creates a war
that comes about from his greed for gold
that doesn't even exist nevertheless he
continues to look for it with no problem
killing whoever or whatever is in his
way he's so awful that his dog Percy
even leaves his side in the end while
his men do all the work he just relaxes
an attentive luxury his only real goal
is to find gold and to live his life as
a rich man he uses his position to
corrupt the system and get what he wants
he has no morals which allows him to get
away with practically anything easily
Claude Frollo if you haven't seen the
Hunchback of Notre Dom you probably
wouldn't consider it the darkest movie
in the Disney franchise but oh if you
have then you know how crazy sad this
film is Claude Frollo shunned Quasimodo
from society after murdering his mother
he calls Quasimodo a monster all the
time and tells him to be grateful for
the solace of the cathedral because
society would not treat him like a human
being anyway because of his physical
features the sad part is that he isn't
exactly wrong and telling quasi this
because the public does eventually make
a fool out of him luckily as Morell to
show some kindness but all that does is
upset Frollo because of this Frollo
hunts her down lusting after her then
deciding he's okay with hurting her
after she denies his advances of
marriage he is so angry that he burns
down the entire city to find her this
film shows themes of
Green and just pure evil fro though it's
similar to Ratcliffe in the way that he
deals with abusing power to get what he
wants
however he governs a lot more people now
all of China knows you're here Shan you
just looking at Shan you from Mulan can
instill fear in the bravest of us even
if he is animated he's a threat because
of his strength and military ranking we
see him hurt people in cold blood to
show that he's no one to mess with this
message is sent to the opposing side to
evoke fear and doubt men are shaking in
their boots when he comes around because
he is that powerful and scary he escapes
an avalanche basically untouched and
that definitely warrants some respect
but it's Mulan who stands up to him and
he treats her no different than he would
fighting a man Shan Yu doesn't care if
Mulan is male or female he still wants
to hurt her his superhuman strengths
make him fit to survive an avalanche and
cold climates he is extremely tall and
built invoking fear and anyone willing
to fight against him scar if you have
watched The Lion King there is no way
you didn't tear up as Skaar hurt his
brother
ask yourself if you've gotten over it
it's something that will get you every
time you watch it scar is not only
responsible for hurting the King to take
to the throne but he then convinces his
nephew that he is responsible for his
dad's passing full of guilt Simba runs
away and Skaar has the throne of Pride
Rock with scars King he basically ruins
the once beautiful land and everything
turns to dust he lies to everyone about
the death of Mufasa and why Simba has
left this causes the land to become
abandoned with no sense of hope of
revival scar has always had dark desires
to rule over a kingdom where everyone
pledges their loyalty to him scar admits
that he was gifted with intelligence
over Mufasa being given power and
strength his evil plans make him a
powerful villain hurting the king who is
also your brother and getting away with
it untouched deserved recognition doctor
facile ear in the film The Princess and
the Frog
dr. fossil ears of voodoo priest he is
oftentimes referred to as a charlatan or
a faker but hates being called that
man I've got friends on the other side
he says this is true based on Haitian
Vodou culture people in this position do
actually talk to the dead through magic
this form of Voodoo is seen in the lawn
of Hollywood films fasoli air possesses
powerful magic and is pretty good at
using it he is capable of accomplishing
pretty much anything he can think of his
favorite trick deals with playing cards
because he can manipulate them he's
basically a witch doctor who is also
responsible for hurting ray and turning
prince naveen into a frog Ursula in
order to marry a man she met a few days
ago
Ariel also known as the Little Mermaid
is ready to abandon her home family and
friends while this isn't the smartest
decision to start with Ursula still
tricks Ariel into a horrific deal
Ariel thinks Ursula is her Savior
because she can give her what she wants
which is the ability to live on land and
marry the Prince Eric many people would
probably jump the thought of meeting
their soulmate for a small fee but the
decision is just naive an Ariel super
young in return
Ursula captures Ariel's voice but
despite being voiceless Ariel is still
able to win Eric over with her beauty
and personality Ursula has magical
powers ones that can really only be used
for evil she deceives naive and innocent
people with empty promises that only
hurt them in the end she's as good a
liar as she is with her magical
abilities even if she could use her
powers for good she probably wouldn't
because where's the fun in that
Jafar Jafar is definitely a psychopath
with a side of large ego in Aladdin he
abuses his power as the Royal vizier all
while hiding his evil desires for
everyone he comes in contact with he
also has a parrot that he names after
one of Shakespeare's most awful villains
that is famous for his ability to lie
and deceive they are truly a perfect
match
throughout history snakes are seen as
evil and sneaky Jafar turns himself into
a snake and performs a lot of dark magic
he can hide from others with no issue
and abuses his high authority position
so that he can rule the kingdom by
hurting the Sultan his final mistake was
turning himself into a genie which was
ultimately his doom however if Jafar
were freed
it wouldn't be good for anyone a
psychopath indeed the Evil Queen this
evil queen and Snow White and the Seven
Dwarves is undoubtedly evil because she
views Snow White as a threat she hires a
woodsman to cut her heart out she could
have definitely had her shipped
somewhere else but instead she decides
to hurt Snow White
while Snow White is protected by her
kindness and gains friends from the
Seven Dwarves and woodland animals the
Queen still uses magic to bring Snow
White down this evil Queen has ruled her
kingdom for years and has no problem
hurting whoever she does not like she
uses a Hindman to get rid of Snow White
forever and magically traps people in
inanimate objects
not exactly a person who want to upset
her bad side seems to end with people
passing away she does however give Snow
White the option of chocolate over an
apple when poisoning her which should
count for something right let us leave
our noble Prince with these happy
thoughts
Maleficent with a name that literally
means doing evil or harm what can you
expect from the lady
Maleficent targets a newborn baby which
is kind of harsh the baby is known as
Princess Aurora and she receives a curse
from good ol Maleficent on her 16th
birthday Aurora is set to fall into a
deep sleep forever after her finger has
been pricked by the spinning wheel
Maleficent is rejected by society and is
determined to see this curse through
after not being invited to Aurora's
christening and decides to make the
family anticipate the day of her passing
away
Maleficent power lies in her ability to
put fear into the entire kingdom and
what she is capable of magically she is
always angry and acts on her anger she
also can morph into a dragon they should
have sent her in invites Chernabog going
back to the 40's for a Disney classic
villain if you aren't familiar with
Chernabog this villain comes from the
1940s Disney film Night on Bald Mountain
while this movie was probably before
your time this villain fits right in on
this list
he is truly demonic and is based on
chair nabob a deity he went by the black
god this villain is so powerful that min
evil are
that he is Disney's best representation
of pure evil
this is because he chooses to be evil
with no specific backstory no jealousy
and no motive being evil is just what he
likes to do he wants only to devour and
destroy Chernabog has no goals but has
servants fulfilling all of his desires
he also has no personality or weaknesses
evilness is a lifestyle for him that's
it for who is the most powerful Disney
villain do you agree with our ranking
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]